on Saturdays I like to keep it pretty
low-key a cup of coffee Oh baby exercise
and then maybe really stretch myself in
hi I'm Aparna global warming climate
change that one polar bear floating on
an ice cap
we've all heard and seen these things
but how will they affect us directly I
do know that most of the scientific
community agrees that the earth is
honored to Jack turi to warm up anywhere
between two and four degrees Celsius in
the next 70 years but what will living
in a world that is 4 degrees Celsius
hotter actually mean for us will it be
Spring Break forever hashtag Yolo
hashtag best life I'm not even prepared
for that but to truly answer this
question I brought together a team of
experts that will help us see what it
will be like to live in a world that is
4 degrees celcius hotter and as Fung is
a researcher studying the effects of
climate change and Janet George's chief
data officer at Western Digital so what
is a four sea world I feel like a lot of
people would hear that will be four
degrees hotter and they'll be like
that's not that much harder well when we
think about a few degrees it's globally
average during the Ice Age it was only
for C coder okay as sea level was
dramatically lower so how is data
changing the game for climate science we
have tremendous data in our hands we
have deep insights from this data we are
able to analyze its scale that we've
never been able to do before we were
able to build machine learning models
that tell us predictive analytics around
what we can see that impacts climate
change a lot of irreversible changes are
going to happen to to the world heat
waves will be very long and together
with the heat waves we have very long
droughts and then when it rains the rain
is going to be more intense it may be
different durations and then what we
also see is sea level rise
there will be tremendous inundation for
the coastal region you know this is why
that's why I don't care about climate
change action it's a lot of talking and
not a lot of what's in it for me
mass extinction yeah so I'm gonna be
honest you said a lot of important stuff
but it's all pretty terrible sounding
and at some points I had to tune out
just to stay positive you need to talk
to people in a way that they can really
you know they can be like well what
would be different for me like you got
to hit him where it hurts
maybe if you were like I'm gonna put you
in a foresee world and take away your
weekend and experiment yeah an
experiment like do an experiment okay
well I like your positive attitude I
think if we showed me going through my
Saturday and everything's the same
except it's a four SeaWorld now that I
would watch ready when you are
hmm nothing better than waking up to a
room full of strangers don't talk to
Janet and an S through there somebody's
talking to me hey good morning
congratulations you don't live near the
coast and your home is still here no
I've always said that nature is smarter
than we are in a forsee world there will
be surprises and there will be surprises
that we really cannot anticipate
[Music]
no don't go under the bed don't wonder
this it's not appropriate I just met you
please stop
I actually feel for her hello Jenny yes
cockroaches wait what does that have to
do with the four sea world in fact
behavior is keenly sensitive to
temperature fluctuations data has also
shown a strong correlation between
rising temperatures dna-based
substitution and DNA replication why are
you telling me this
are you trying to help it doesn't seem
like you're helping it's over the rising
temperatures and as these genetics
become diverse and what we are going to
see is new behaviors and new adaptations
emerging from these insects that we
didn't actually predict or know about
please stay down there the whole food
chain the whole biological system is
changing in a way that we cannot predict
because we have no data for that future
system get these guys birds which
species will thrive I cannot really tell
you but given the long history of
cockroaches I think that they would do
well I don't trust you okay thank you
for your time please never come back
don't mind if I do even though I'm
fairly certainly this is a trap
she's addicted to coffee and I think she
has to realize that in a 4c world coffee
is going to be very precious what could
go wrong wake up that's really rude and
nasty why why did you do that we have
heard some people say that all climate
change we can just move the coffee
uphill where it is cooler it's not that
easy data measurement and analysis
capabilities have improved we are
gaining a much deeper understanding of
what the issues are the mechanisms that
we can incorporate into the models we
face the danger of the native Arabica
plant going extinct and those diversity
banks are very key for studying
long-term sustainability to cultivate
new crop thank you this makes up for
earlier why we're really racing against
the clock and there could be a lot of
trial and error while we're
experimenting and figuring out where to
go and where to plot here's the good
news data is actually helping us solve
the problem for example the
inter-american Development Bank released
the genome of Arabica coffee plant in
2014 to the public domain now with
crowdsourcing you have this concept of
distributed brain and so you know
scientists all over the world that has
any knowledge or has data around coffee
can now input this into the system this
actually helps us to understand how
coffee plants like Arabica can survive
in warmer temperatures
[Music]
Oh exercise haven't done this in a while
you know what it's a beautiful day and
what is the worst thing you guys can do
to me out here
Touche I stand corrected without fitted
you with enough insulation to bring your
body temperature up so that you can feel
what it is like in the 40 environment I
think you feel very cocooned co2 is
trapping the heat that otherwise would
have escaped to space so the earth can't
breathe cannot ventilate so it is like
the earth is heating up and we say
here's another layer of blanket put on
another sweater
Appanna how are you feeling no I don't
like that we want to make sure that we
simulate difficult breathing conditions
for her in a 4c world in a 4c world
wildfires could last a lot longer in
California alone we've seen it affect
the air quality not just for a single
day but we've seen the toxic air quality
continue and be prolonged for weeks
climate change is not just about
temperature change climate changes the
whole slew of things happening all
together
for example warmer air can hold more
water vapor then cooler air when it
rains it's going to be more intense and
in places that precipitation may be
declining there may be flash floods
because we can have intense downpours
oh there's going to be a whole host of
outcomes and because the world is
totally interconnected we cannot be
business as usual oh it's so nice are
you kidding me in the Farsi world
there'll be severe water shortages and
there's no such thing as long showers
you really hate you guys
is it time for a drink
no no this is the restaurant that
simulates a 4c world and we've set you
up on a blind date but you guys haven't
even let me shower today
don't worry this a new face deodorant
I'm putting it on my face
[Music]
well here's her blind date to my big
girl in oh oh oh this is nice who knows
if restaurants of the future will have
oxygen bars but wouldn't that be fun
all-around awkward sure why not it's
very hot in here they're wider does
anyone work here well nobody can afford
the rent now so I don't know who will be
able to afford the rent when there's
less land we thought for the land in San
Francisco we're going to shrink about 20
square miles now we can measure the
distance of the ground very accurately
with lidar and with radar flying on
satellites and on aircraft now we know
that the land can shrink to 50 square
miles do you work here as much fun as
we're having with Aparna here this is a
really serious issue that's going to
affect the world's poor when climate
change happens when sea level rises they
have nowhere to go is this person not a
real human is that the twist he's not a
robot he's real you were definitely a
robot why are we standing here let's go
sit down
oh I'm so hungry I just want some
sustenance anything 76 percent of the
world's population depend on rice wheat
barley and potatoes for their protein
hey what can I get you oh thank goodness
um two burgers and three glasses of
water and whatever he would like data
from experiments have shown that plants
grown in a higher co2 world will have
less protein I am so excited for this
food
so with decreased protein content of
these crops we're gonna have a protein
deficiency crisis what what is this the
way you have here is a burger made out
of crickets topped with some toasted
super worms as creepy as it is in a 4c
world eating insects may be the
practical thing to our protein problems
especially since animal husbandry is
going to be very expensive and
unpredictable I mean there's good
texture so how did it go oh I'm swiping
left
I think I'm swiping left on the whole
day you know what happened in there is
based on our model projections and the
models aren't perfect we really have no
clue how citizens and governments will
respond to the climate change so we
cannot wallow in our in our sense of
hopelessness no action is very dangerous
you know I think there's progress the UK
has actually done some pretty good work
they have been able to reduce carbon
emission doubles to pre-industrial
revolution levels so I think that's
massive progress how do you think data
has helped to overcome some climate
hurdles you know if you think about data
data was simply just information and we
didn't have the ability to collect very
large amounts of it
Meishan today we can not only collect
very large amounts of information we can
stitch all this information together to
create knowledge and thus insight so I
think data is definitely a big piece of
the puzzle but along with that is what
we do with the data it was fascinating
to see how scientists are able to use
data to make well-founded predictions
about what might happen when we're
living in a 4c world even small changes
in complex ecosystems could potentially
lead to some pretty wild outcomes but I
am signing off with a degree of hope
find out more about how data is helping
the world take climate action that data
makes possible calm now if you'll excuse
me I need to go talk to my therapist
about cockroaches
you